he couldn't be with us here tonight but
your set decorator was was hoping to
join us and and I think Peter you have
mentioned in the past that that the
rooms were felt very much like the rooms
that you as a boy would have expected it
to be and that that the placement of
everything the costumes the the the set
the props all the things were very much
something or you felt you were walking
into that world so could you talk a
little bit about the work that he did
and the work that you do together to
create those environments yeah we had
Ralphie's bedroom in Cleveland and in
Toronto and we had the entrance to the
house in Cleveland and we had the
entrance to the house in Toronto as well
where the lamp comes into the into the
front door area but I must send a big
shout out out to to mark Freeborn who
unfortunately couldn't be with us but
mark was the heart and soul of the
wonderful texture and authenticity of
those props and of those interiors he
and his crew collected and and put
together a pageant where I would just
come in and just laugh and just say uh
guys this is incredibly perfect they did
an amazing job
yeah and the slide too I'll tell you all
because we get a lunch break and most
people go back to the trip we just slid
down that thing the entire time during
lunch frontwards backwards pushing each
other testing each other then they
called us back to work and that was so
we loved it it was really great and it
really made it was an easy environment
to work in because of the design and the
detail that you both did you felt like
you were in a bedroom you'd pick up the
toys and they felt even though I hadn't
been from that time period they felt
real you had real toys a lot of times on
sets things are fake or you're trying to
cut corners or it's just a facade front
all the detail you know and just in the
in the clothing and the fabric and the
toys it just that whole environment made
it so much easier to sort of immerse
into the character and to work and I
would spend a lot of time and just in
the bedroom are looking at the notebooks
and touching and Bob encouraged that
just to get comfortable in those it just
seemed easier
it just seemed to all come together in a
very synergetic seamless nothing before
nothing came before anything else you
know it was just a complete picture and
you know I mean I Altima it's just Bob
and a great script you know and
everybody got it and you know just just
embraced it but it just seemed not so
difficult we all bought into it we all
bought into the level of detail and the
irony and the humor we all felt the same
things that gene was communicating in
his narration and the level of detail is
I think what gives the movie much of its
longevity is because those little pieces
have become iconic